[Music]  how do you feel except that you told me  right after that you were exhausted now  did you realize that you're actually a  winner of the tournament  i mean uh  i think i was more or less sure like  when having like two points advantage 50  rounds to go  but uh yeah the job had to be done and i  mean then we like  i finished quite you know quite quickly  the previous game and uh  of course uh it was  not so obvious when until okay the  game between ding and java was over  uh so i mean even  even though like with with this  two-point advantage it was like  mathematically it was a chance uh to  screw everything up yeah  so um yeah i  couldn't really chill until you know the  game was over  [Music]  and there he is and that's the way it is  it's not over till it's over i have to  mention because i've been doing some  math in my head so it's seven thousand  for every point yeah we've got something  to add up